hey reject nation how you doin Tara
Erikson's back Mahoney know what we're
in jean jackets jean jacket look how
sexy she look don't you like check out
her channel anytime you guys think about
a girl you're like Oh what do I want to
wear jean jacket era you know who also
wears jean jackets often oh no no no
Brian really he actually does he's one
of my heroes this has been requested
from a lot of people come on in jordan
shlonsky planned their trip to italy do
you know anything about the jordan
shlonsky and conan experience I don't
okay Jordan shlonsky is one of his
producers and he has a weird personality
robotic and knowledgeable but he hardly
breaks and Conan just constantly rifts
off his weirdness and makes fun of him a
lot amazing and they always do these
remotes together they do a lot because
he's just such a strange human being
I'll introduce you I ain't too strange
that's why you got chip nail nails the
triple Nils that's my quote triple Nils
god bless opening up and Reseda
Boulevard yeah you've spoken so much
about Italy you talked so much about
Italy that many people think you're from
Italy you drove a Vespa for a while it's
right until someone just ran into you
destroyed
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes other places that I like in a
nutshell I mean I've been everywhere
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
but often I find myself connecting with
shop buy yourself travel often alone and
I have romantic evenings under the stars
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
which is prefer not to say the name it's
a special place well my favorite
restaurant is there and like I say I
have a special connection with the
people there and my picture is hanging
on the wall and we're gonna have a
cappuccino we're not gonna mess around
with any of the American coffee drink
for America what do you say I would ask
if I had espresso I wouldn't expect it
to be good you say 2fo who's been
working there 16 years I'll order if I
don't expected to be good is that what
you say I don't say all my thoughts out
loud what are you thinking right now I
can push this through right now it's our
party you died about a week way
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes I haven't kept count but I would
assume 25 times approximately why don't
the money for this Jordan you paid that
money I pay that much that you've been
to Italy at least 25 to 30 times and
tasted the very best food state of the
nicest hotels that's how much I pay you
yes okay and what do you turn do you do
for me camera caught people that happens
sometimes but let's continue this
[Laughter]
mother's milk use it to build up the fat
in your body so you can go over here
you're slaving away very strict rules
governing bear up pizza not police you
have to be there in 30 minutes or less
una
this was the cover of douche Wheatley Oh
his story actual iPad my goodness
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
based on public perception what might
the public find to be unattractive about
your face is that the question
[Laughter]
you know to moisturize I went to Italy
that night it was intense me Gatos
that's a cool tease ever since he got
the TBS he's done a lot of going to a
contrary for a week and then doing a
whole week dedicated to being in this
other country right that's cool the how
like a tease set up for what they're
gonna do Italy and for a guy who has
seen the very early beginnings of the
cult Conan and Jordan shlonsky bits
this is especially delightful for me
because slansky never breaks really
sometimes you like cracks a smile but
it's very rare it's even obvious
sometimes they'll do retakes if he
doesn't do that but to see him break was
like whoa he's like actually just break
I don't know how he stays like that it's
hard to do conan man he's my favorite
it's hard to do anytime who I can't who
can prank somebody or like I don't know
hang out with a comedian and then just
like not laugh at all you're in the
comedy world are there a lot of
comedians especially try not to laugh at
each other's jokes I know I'm a very
supportive comedian I laugh at other
people's jokes because they deserve the
laughs otherwise you want to go home go
wow you well very very was it 2d very
meta there sometimes you just want to go
home and so I laugh at other people's
jokes that's good no that's very
supportive of you I would love to be on
Conan so bad is he alright well write
him a letter
tell him hey Conan I do jokes for about
five people once a month my friend great
he has a YouTube channel he wants to be
on your show all the best love hug kiss
hug kiss tera Erickson www.youtube.com
and then www.youtube.com/watch v rejects
yeah and bring me on and be like I've
brought you on Greg because this 10 year
old girl submitted a letter to me yeah
and I'm she added Hello Kitty stickers
you all over it just touched his heart a
lot yeah when he meets me and I'm like
yo it up
Conan what up that Ted your old girl you
think Conan's attractive would you date
Conan look at him right there no no no
you want it like initially looking at
him I don't think he's that he's not
like my I don't know if I have a type
but looking at him I'm not like oh wow I
think he's really cute and I'd want to
date him if I met him in person because
he would make me laugh I was money I
don't care about the money
laugh let's do this and he would
probably be able to make me laugh then
it'd be like who are you wouldn't get
married now but initially just glancing
at Conan and his face no personality no
dating no it's Conan and his face
personality dating swipe right let's do
the thing I feel like if you met a guy
with enough money who wanted to date you
I think that would matter to you oh no
what a snoozefest
try not to be to buy a house for me and
then I out what I wander around and
don't ever laugh again and want to blow
my brains out after day to know Thank
You Gregory out just cheating and then
you have to come home to a snoozefest
who gives a Shh aren't you from another
channel yeah I mean I'm buddy I want
laughs I want hugs in life it's hard to
laugh on your poor
spread hugs love and laughter that is a
little bit true you need food in the
fridge mmm it does get very sad when I
look at my fridge and I just have vegan
slices of cheese and almond milk that
apparently expires maybe I would marry
up for a week get divorced give me the
money
then I'd marry for love no I wouldn't do
that I would just be poor I would just
be poor and I'm not even just saying
that I'm transition to the outro go
ahead do do transition go ahead just do
go ahead transition to the outro Greg
you don't have to tell me when you're
gonna transition you just do it guys can
you speak right reject nation yeah yeah
yeah sure sure sure
ring ring ring ring ring yeah yeah ring
the bell you're supposed to yeah Tara
has a channel and listen subscribe to me
cuz I'm the one who's marrying for love
over here okay not money morals are you
like tall african-american gentleman
yeah I like old men gentlemen all
gentlemen of all types dated a ginger
before it's happened he was shorter than
me too
that's sad he had zero money he had
three I think I better